gentlemen ladies what if Superman had
decided to fly down rip off the roof of
the White House
grab the president right out of the Oval
Office who would have stopped him I want
to build a team of some very bad people
who I think can do some good
y'all Joker's must be crazy
what
this is the deal you disobey me you die
try to escape you die
no boyfriend you irritate or vex me I'm
known to be quite vexing I'm just
forewarning you you die they get caught
we throw them under the bus
I'm gonna ride this boy mom got
something better too
I love this guy
not good don't forget for the bad guys
are you sweet-talking me all of that
chit chats gonna get charged with a wick
ride
we'll do you want seesaw oh yeah one who
sings dog yes I want to see stop I was
just trying to get you there
no hard feelings all right we good
what you having beer whiskey what am i
12
how are you hot stuff water that's a
good idea huh what was that I should
kill everyone and escape sorry
the voices I'm kidding
that's not what they release